do want to mention this NBC
News has a report about the person of
the year maybe you've heard uh already
the news the big news says no single
person this year has captivated public
conversation quite like Taylor Swift so
much so the Time Magazine has named her
it's 2023 person of the
year
um Swift beat a wide- ranging pool of
finalists including
Barbie Barbie was in the like the
Ki okay former president Donald Trump's
prosecutors and Britain's recently
coordinated King Charles III but uh
Taylor Swift was named the person of the
year now I know that um this is the part
where you're expecting me to launch into
a whole rant about how Taylor Swift is
dumb and shouldn't be person of the year
and like yeah she is dumb and she
shouldn't be person of the year but and
and I know that that that many
conservatives have been complaining
about this and every year we get the
person of the year and conservatives
pretty much always complain about
whoever it is it's like it's an annual
tradition and uh and I get that you know
it's a tradition so we we I like
traditions but I will say that you know
I'm not a Taylor Swift fan so this is g
to be unpopular opinion probably among
the
audience I'm not a Taylor Swift fan and
yes she's a dumb leftist and all that
and yeah her music is vapid and annoying
but like I think it makes sense that
she's person of the year like I heard
that and I thought okay yeah it makes
sense sure I could see
that and then I see the reaction from a
lot of people on the right this is what
how's it Taylor Swift what do you mean
what do you mean how's it Taylor Swift
didn't she have like three number one
albums this year the the top three
albums are all hers and uh she had a
tour the biggest tour of all time and a
you know one of the biggest selling one
of the one of one of the top uh grossing
films of the year so she dominated every
category of
media and then and then Sports too she
became the top story in the NFL I'm not
saying I like that I just it just
literally every every category of media
she dominated and
um I'm not I
don't I don't prefer
that but it it's like it's kind of
impressive isn't it it's it's a little
bit I mean it's a little
impressive are we actually going to
pretend oh it's just three number one
albums I could do that I could do that
in a year the top three albums who
cares that's that's
nothing so I don't really get the
complaints um time has made some bizarre
choices for person of the year but
choosing someone who who again dominated
literally every form of media I think
it's
understandable and I realize that as I
say this I'm not beating the charge that
I'm a closet Swifty and that is a theory
in some circles my producer McKenna was
accusing me of that recently it's
totally spous baseless
accusation just because I saw her in
concert three times this year suddenly
I'm a fan just because I spent $147,000
on front row tickets three times
suddenly I'm a I'm a big fan now get a
grip and I'm not I'm not saying that I
would have named Taylor Swift person the
year but really but who else would even
make I was thinking about this this
morning who because usually they they
name Person of the Year and it's someone
stupid and you and you go well it
obviously should have been this person
but who even who would it be like their
other their other Runners the runner up
was a toy the runner up with someone who
doesn't even
exist I guess it was kind of a Down year
for Humanity I'm realizing like no one
really did anything good this year no
one did anything interesting this year
this this year sucked it did your online
data includes personal information such
as your name address phone number email
address financial information and login
credentials hackers want to steal this
information and sell it on the dark web
where it can be used for various
criminal activities such as fishing
ramps andwar and identity theft needless
to say it's incredibly important that
you use a VPN to prevent that from
happening but choosing a VPN you trust
is equally as important that's why I
recommend using expressvpn every time
you go online Express UPN makes you
anonymous online by camouflaging your IP
address and replacing it with a
different secure IP of your choice
Express VPN also encrypts all of your
data so that it's protected from hackers
and anyone else that's trying to spy on
you express VPN is incredibly easy to
use just fire up the app and click one
button plus it works on all my devices
my phone laptop even my Wi-Fi router so
if you're like me and believe that your
internet data belongs to you then
expressvpn is the answer visit
expressvpn.com walow get three extra
months free that's
expressvpn.com
Walsh show expressvpn
.at Walsh show to learn more Elon Musk
really he's the guy it should have been
Elon Musk he's the only one who did
anything interesting this year and um I
think he won recently there's no way
they're going to give it to him again
like there was no way that after this
year it was it was not going to happen
they were not gonna if they had given
Elon Musk Time person of year there
would have been like Angry mobs at Time
Magazine headquarters burning it to the
ground and so they weren't going to do
that wasn't going to be Elon Musk so if
it's not Elon
Musk then who would it be i' I'd be
interested to hear this from
conservative uh complaining about Taylor
Swift who do you even think it should be
be be be real about it who should it
be I mean it could have been me so
really it was going to be me or Taylor
Swift it was down to one of one of the
two of us and they gave it to Swift and
if I'm not mad about that about if I'm
if I as the person who was jipped here
if I'm not mad then you shouldn't be
either hey YouTube thanks for listening
to the show if you'd like access to my
full show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there